[Applaudissements]
vous avez fait plein d'émissions de
promo c'est vrai que parce que vous êtes
une très bonne cliente les gens quand on
dit on a un bel bent en invité on se dit
toujours on va rigoler pas sa grande et
anecdotes
al'inverse quand je quand je fais pas
une émission télé ya plein de gens qui
m'appellent qui dit ce qu'est ce qu'il y
à t tricard ah ouais c'est pourquoi
était pas pourquoi t'es pas dans
l'émission je fais tellement d'émissions
de télé que quand je suis pas sur une
émission de télé l'entreprise avait même
dit m pas sur cette chaîne n'était pas
le bon elle m'a dit ça anormalement
cognac chimène badi amel bent d'ailleurs
lui même va t elle venir avec de camille
combal jusqu'à qu'est ce qui s'est passé
est pas je suis blessé ou ça c'est pas
encore
si vous regardez la tête de tapha on
dirait dj bourdon dans le sketch
stéphanie de monaco
c'est quoi cette tête allez c'est parti
attention le deuxième coup on y va avec
[Musique]
aura-t-il à la mode
amine avocat
ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas encore